[MUSIC]
When it comes to the question of
whether you dive in head first or
whether you take baby steps, I think
the answer is probably that you do both.
Meaning you find a place where you
know you can make a difference.
So, maybe that's going to be through
the automation of infrastructure, or
maybe that's going to be
improving test coverage.
Maybe it's going to be implementing
some continuous integration, or
even a step toward continuous delivery.
And you should really dive in with the
full intention to realize that value.
At the same time though you want Sir
Vigrid principles to be able to work for
you in this context.
So, I don't know how a mountain
goat approaches the mountain right.
But I think it's with the intention
of getting where it wants to go but
how does it do?
It it takes a tentative step and
each time it tests a little bit, right.
How did that work for
me and then moves forward and I think
that's the way that you should do it, so
you should bring your whole self
your whole intention to the effort.
I mean just give an example of what
going all the end could mean in
a negative way or in a different
context and you are then you by all
the things [LAUGH] you write, you buy
all the software, you hire a giant team.
I don't think you have
to start in that way.
I think what you have to be clear
about is where you want to get to and
what thing you're going to
do first to make an impact.
And I think that's
the thing you go all in on.
[MUSIC]
Often, the places where a DevOps
Engineer is going to be asked to start
working are in the places where the
organization is feeling the most pain or
is suffering the most.
So, I guess there's nobility there
in the same way that there is for
an early responder.
I don't want to make
this overly dramatic.
There's a book that I really love,
it's called Your Code Is A Crime Scene.
And if that's real and there's some
evidence to support that idea,
the DevOps Engineer shows
up in that space and
is going to work to make things better.
So all in, on an area in
which you can make an effort,
that's really going to pay off.
All in on some global sense,
like I have to decide early on
what tooling I pay for, I have to decide
early on what methodologies I use.
I think that might be a mistake.
As a matter of fact,
you'd be creating structure
ahead of any kind of learning and
that might be damaging.
So, I like the mountain goat metaphor.